my mother is a talent agent and she's
90. I love that she's 90
Beast yeah
but it's but you know it's funny and for
your mom's generation unlike ours and
definitely the kids her 90 your 90 is
going to be better you're going to be
you're going to feel younger it's the
way it works I was thinking about it the
other day
what has she done that I do that I love
you know she really has always
encouraged young people always I know
you talk a lot about young people but
you know that it resonates oh I'm very
aware I get the DMs I read it it's a
universal message come desperately be
passionate about people 35 to 60
understanding how many more years they
have I love your life thank you thank
you such a pleasure thank you for saying